Don't cast that spell it's too dangerous why
we tampered with the stability of space time
the multiverse is a concept about
which we know frighteningly level
your
it was the only way
but i never meant for any of this to happen
wanda
I knew somewhere later you'd show up
I made mistakes and people were hurt
i'm not here to talk about westview
then what are you here for i need your help
guess what what do you know about the multiverse
i'm sorry steven i hope you understand
the greatest threat
to our universe
is you
things just got out of hand
Welcome back everyone this will be my full doctor
strange multiverse of madness trailer video marvel
dropped the official trailer nice shiny footage
there's a bunch of easter eggs so we'll break
it all down yes this was the spider-man no way
home post-credits scene and it was basically the
trailer that they just attached to the end of
the movie so if you're brand new to the channel
be sure to subscribe to get all the videos we're
doing a giveaway for imax tickets for the movie
all you have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and just leave your favorite easter egg from the
trailer on the video but now that we actually
have the full trailer online it's a little bit
easier to talk about all these moments for people
that either haven't seen the movie yet or who are
just waiting for the trailer to drop the big thing
they're teasing here obviously that it's going to
be focused on a lot of doctor strange's variants
if we're getting into loki kang multiverse war
easter eggs so there's a lot of similarities and
i believe that a version of loki is also supposed
to show up during this movie at some point but it
starts with a bunch of voice over dialogue from
spider-man no way home from different parts of
the movie where wong is yelling at doctor strange
don't perform that spell talking about the spell
to make everyone forget that peter parker was
spider-man careful for spoilers for spider-man
no way home just because i do have to talk about
some stuff that happens during that movie with the
spell because it's critical for what's happening
during multiverse of madness so when spider-man
botches the spell it creates all these tears
in reality and it sort of reverses the intended
effect of the spell so everybody who knows
peter parker is spider-man from every single
universe in the multiverse slowly starts to
come to the mcu like they're pulled by magnet but
doctor strange stops the spell and contains it
before it can get worse but then at the end of
the movie when his box gets blown up the spell
gets released it gets worse and reality starts
to tear all over the place like you're tearing
a painting in half probably the worst thing that
could possibly happen next the kang multiverse war
when he performs the second spell to make everyone
forget peter parker just in general that sort of
stops the negative effects but it doesn't reverse
any of the damage that they caused before so later
in the trailer when you hear baron mordo yelling
at doctor strange your desecration of reality will
not go unpunished and he says the greatest threat
to the multiverse is you he's obviously talking
about all the different doctor strange variants
not just our mcu doctor strange but it's the
idea that each of these different doctor strange
variants do something really terrible to mess up
reality it's sort of a contest that all the marvel
phase four characters are having to see who can
mess up the multiverse the worst so it'll be fun
to see all these different doctor strange variants
and find out what they did in their own realities
then they have the dialogue from spider-man no
way home of doctor strange telling spider-man that
the multiverse is a concept about which they have
very little information about which they know
very little and they also include that line of
dialogue from doctor strange in avengers infinity
war when he's talking to iron man saying this was
the only way before he got snapped by thanos the
one way in 14 million that they beat thanos so
it's just another reference to the way that they
fundamentally altered reality to bring everyone
back that was a plot point during spider-man no
way home as well where he tells spider-man we
changed reality fundamentally to bring back half
of the universe and you want me to do it again
just because you're having a bad time they show
you doctor strange's broken watch from the first
doctor strange movie that christine gave him i
talked about this during my last doctor strange
video but i love that they're using the imagery of
the broken watch because obviously it's important
for his personal relationship to christine who
we see getting married to someone else during
the trailer but also the idea that time is broken
the whole thing with kang and the multiverse war
master of time time travel villain the idea that
doctor strange messing with reality also includes
the timelines this looks like it could have
been a scene right out of what if episode 4
the doctor strange episode where doctor strange
supreme destroys his entire reality to try and
undo an absolute point in time so that his
christine won't die like all of reality is
slowly breaking down on a fundamental level like i
said before i believe that this sanctum belongs to
one of the other doctor strange variants maybe the
evil version doctor strange or the evil looking
version that could be the live-action version of
doctor strange supreme or it might just be another
version who just looks a little bit like him
either way they're trying to make us think from
the way they cut the trailer that that is the main
villain of the film like it's going to be one of
the doctor strange variants or one of the worst
variants the same way that he who remains king
during the loki finale said that he might be bad
like you might think that i'm the devil but wait
till you meet my variants they're way worse than
i am i love the custom marvel studios logo with a
broken looking prism like it's meant to represent
all these alternate facets all these different
doctor strange variants but also in these
different facets they show you different versions
of the marvel studios logo that we've had over the
different eras of the films during the different
phases like during the marvel phase 1 movies the
marvel studios intro logo looked like this during
marvel phase 2 it changed again just a little bit
then during marvel phase 3 they changed it again
and the more modern one during marvel phase 4
looks like this now the pictures in the logo
in the background too as the pages kind of flip
like they used to do in the marvel studios logo or
just from the doctor strange comics i was actually
looking for some x-men in here like zoom enhanced
do we see any x-men in the background here but
also the idea that reality is breaking like
the reality of the mcu like you would normally
think of it with this logo is breaking into many
different pieces as if all the times the doctor
strange and the avengers have messed with reality
using the infinity stones during infinity war and
avengers end game and then during spider-man no
way home with the spell have just fundamentally
fractured reality more and more along with what
the other doctor strange variants have been
doing in their own universes then i guess i'm not
totally surprised that he's not yelling at wanda
because of what happened with wandavision the hex
in westview they only have about two and a half
hours to get through the plot of this movie so
they'll probably brush over briefly what happened
during the events of wandavision like she seems
very remorseful about what happened for those of
you asking yes he does know about the darkhold
because we see him using it later in the trailer
so obviously he's here to get her help because she
is powerful he knows about her chaos magic and he
knows that she's gotten much more powerful based
on the way they present this i'm assuming that
the place where he's coming to visit her is near
where the cabin was at the end of the wandavision
post-credits scene but the actual house that's in
this landscape here looks different than the house
from wandavision wanda would know a little bit
about the multiverse after reading the darkhold
for so long i'm assuming it's been a small time
jump since the end of the wandavision post-credits
scene because that was meant to take place
pretty soon after the events of avengers end game
and spider-man no way home ends the christmas of
2024 about a year and a half after the events
of wandavision so you have to assume that doctor
strange multiverse of madness takes place just a
little bit after the end of spider-man no way home
so it's been even longer almost a full two years
so she's had almost two years of studying the dark
hold this is doctor strange going with america
chavez to visit whatever nexus of space time
is represented by this place here it just seems
like this ancient temple that contains some power
source that's critical to whatever they're
trying to do during the movie like it'll be
their infinity stone level item just in terms of
importance it's not totally clear what's going
on here when this cloud moves in on camartage
but when you see this explosion here you can
actually see rintrah the minotaur in this group
with all the other sorcerers he is a powerful
sorcerer from the comics there were a couple other
characters that they featured in the merchandise
too like sleepwalker and despair so we might get
some cameos from those characters in the movie too
they said that they're using a lot of the reshoots
for the movie right now extensive reissues
to put in a bunch of extra cameo scenes and
other cool characters then whatever's going
on here scarlet witch looks like she's casting
some really powerful spell with her chaos magic
levitating in the air but if you look at her
fingers her fingers are going black just like
agatha harkness's fingers went black that could
just be because of how long she's been using the
darkhold and just the way she's using her chaos
magic it could just be part of the toll that's
taken on her body it doesn't look like she has the
darkhold with her here but we see doctor strange
using it here when it looks like he's manipulating
chaos magic so whatever spell he's weaving here
the darkhold is glowing red with chaos magic so
we're all these items that are spinning around him
so it sounds like he's trying to weave
some spell that's inside the darkhold
we get a better look at the spell that doctor
strange weaves when he's trying to protect america
chavez wong is standing next to him here too like
those giant snakes those dragon looking creatures
that just sprout out of his hands then like i said
in my last video this is gargantos it's not shu
mcgorth even though the giant floaty eyeball with
a bunch of tentacles makes you think of schumachet
when he goes to see doctor strange supreme or
evil doctor strange who looks really shady and
says things just got out of hand they're giving
us a lot of loki he who remains vibes with this
whole version of the sanctum here like you see the
event horizon this giant cosmic storm behind them
and this is meant to be the same room that you
see our doctor strange weaving the spell with
the dark hold in except this entire wall of the
sanctum where you would normally see the window
has just been blown out and it just opens up
to the vacuum of space whatever is reality is
breaking down behind them so just meant to let you
know that there are a lot of similarities between
the versions of their characters even though it
seems like they're going to have some fundamental
disagreement about whatever's going on during the
movie but he's just giving off a lot of doctor
strange supreme vibes even though strange supreme
kind of turned good by the end of his series
the other version of doctor strange that we see
during the trailer and during the poster here
like there's a couple different versions of the
poster is defender strange he's the one that wears
the costume that looks like the defenders comic
book costume that's why i'm calling him defender
strange they might call him something different
during the movie you see him with a ponytail
spinning around through dimensions here the
same way we saw our doctor strange in the first
doctor strange movie getting sent through all the
different dimensions by the ancient one then they
reveal the brand new logo for the movie so all the
swirling in the background here is obviously just
reality itself just sort of bleeding into
each other things breaking down things going
completely crazy like a giant cosmic soup all
getting mixed together in a really bad way and
the reason why it looks red in color like reddish
is for red chaos magic implying the scarlet witch
the darkhold chaos magic in general is going to
play a huge role in what's happening during the
events of the film it'll be fun to see how they
invoke some easter eggs for the celestials and
other really big cosmic characters during this
too because obviously irish and the judge the
other celestials during the eternals movie have
their own giant cosmic plan they're crazy powerful
so they would also probably get a little upset
if reality started breaking down around them
i've also already talked about some of the other
cameo scenes and the concept art that we've seen
like full-blown professor x in a version of
his floaty chair from x-men the animated series
with ultron robots there's rumors that michael
fassbender's magneto is also going to get a cameo
so hopefully there'll be some easter eggs for
his relationship with scarlet witch in the comics
i know a lot of people have asked if they're going
to use this to bring deadpool into the mcu because
that seems like another multiverse explainer i
haven't heard any deadpool rumors recently just
the x-men rumors in this movie but if you spotted
any other big easter eggs in the trailer that i
didn't talk about in this video or in my last
doctor strange 2 trailer video just write them
below in the comments and i just posted my hawkeye
episode 6 finale video with kingpin yelena bulova
i think our next big marvel disney plus series
is going to be moon night so that's actually
going to be really really cool while you wait
for everything click here for that full hawkeye
episode 6 finale video and click here for my full
spider-man no way home post credit scene video
thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and i'll see you guys in the next one!